cada vez que un autobús llega al paso
fronterizo de médica límite entre
ucrania y polonia es un revuelo
las temperaturas marcan niveles bajo
cero y la gente está desesperada
muchos de ellos son extranjeros que
vivían en ucrania dicen que han sido
tratados de forma diferente a los
ucranianos en su camino hacia polonia
dejaron entrar a los ucranianos mientras
que los extranjeros fueron segregados la
mayoría eran indios africanos algunos
ingleses que estaban allí y contenidos
escoceses
como gestos nos hicieron esperar en el
frío durante horas
a los ucranianos se les permite utilizar
los autobuses pero nosotros tuvimos que
ir a pie estábamos sorprendidos
en respuesta a los informes sobre los
residentes no ucranianos que son
retenidos en las fronteras la unión
africana dijo que esto es
escandalosamente racista y en violación
del derecho internacional
su parte el embajador polaco ante la onu
negó tales afirmaciones
los nacionales de todos los países que
han sufrido la agresión rusa o cuya vida
está en peligro pueden buscar refugio en
mi país acogemos a personas de 125
nacionalidades hasta esta crisis polonia
había impuesto normas estrictas en
materia de asilo ahora es el país vecino
de ucrania que más refugiados acoge los
funcionarios de la unión europea dicen
que la guerra podría desplazar hasta 7
millones de personas